AND SPOKE TO UKRAINIANS WHO
RISKED THEIR LIVES TO TRY AND
STOP WHAT APPEAR TO BE WAR
CRIMES. APPROACHING THE SOUTHERN
FRONT LINE IN KHERSON. IN THE
LIBERATED CITY. MANY HAVE FLED.
IT'S DECEPTIVELY QUIET. UNTIL
THE RELENTLESS TERROR. THE OFTEN
INDISCRIMINATE, ALMOST DAILY
RUSSIAN SHELLING. WE'VE COME TO
INVESTIGATE A VERY DELIBERATE
HORROR OF THE RUSSIAN OCCUPATION
, SO THE CHILDREN WHO STAYED
HERE WERE UNDER FIVE YEARS OLD.
MOSTLY THIS ORPHANAGE HAD MORE
THAN 40 CHILDREN HERE. ELENA WAS
A NURSE HERE FOR 17 YEARS. A
SINGLE CHILD IS LEFT OPEN, FEEL
EMPTINESS, EMPTINESS. EVERYTHING
IS JUST STOPPED, SHE SAYS. THE
CHILDREN HAD EVERYTHING. THEY
WERE SO HAPPY. THE CHILDREN WERE
HAPPY. NOW IT'S JUST SILENCE AND
SMALL REMINDERS OF THEM. THEIR
NAMES STILL ON EACH LOCKER,
CHILDREN'S HOME IS NOW A CRIME
SCENE. BRELO WARNED US TO
COLLECT THEIR CLOTHES, SAYS
ELENA, THE RUSSIANS AND
COLLABORATORS CALLED IN THE
EVENING AND SAID TO PREPARE THE
CHILDREN FOR THE MORNING BUSSES
ARRIVED AT EIGHT. THE
HEARTBREAKING SCENES CAPTURED
FOR RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA SHARED ON
A RUSSIAN MPS TELEGRAM CHANNEL.
THE BEWILDERED CHILDREN TAKEN
FROM THEIR BELOVED NURSES IN
OCTOBER, TRANSPORTED TO RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED CRIMEA OR RUSSIA ITSELF
, SAY UKRAINIAN INVESTIGATORS,
BUT INSTEAD OF HIDING THIS
ALLEGED WAR CRIME RUSSIANS
ADVERTISED IT. 72 CHILDREN WILL
BE TAKEN TO SAFE CONDITIONS IN
CRIMEA, HE SAYS. I'LL DEFINITELY
GO AND VISIT. INVESTIGATORS SAID
WAS PART OF A PREMEDITATED
RUSSIAN MISSION TO TAKE
UKRAINIAN CHILDREN EVEN TARGETED
HOSPITALS. THERE WAS A LOT OF
PRESSURE BY THE RUSSIANS TO TAKE
THESE CHILDREN, WEREN'T YOU
AFRAID? IT WAS SCARY. VERY VERY
SCARY. SO MUCH PRESSURE SAYS ALL
APPEAL ALASKA TWICE A DAY THEY
DEMANDED. WE SHOW THEM LISTS OF
THE KIDS TO TAKE TO RUSSIA,
POLAND, HER TEAM CAME UP WITH AN
EXTRAORDINARY DECEPTION. THE
HEAD ORPHANS IN THE ICU FORGED
MEDICAL ASSESSMENTS, SAYING
HEALTHY CHILDREN WERE SEVERELY
SICK. EVEN FAKED AN EMERGENCY
VENTILATION, SHE SAYS. WE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE RUSSIANS AND
COLLABORATORS WOULD NOT FORGIVE
US, SHE SAYS. WE KNEW THERE
WOULD BE SERIOUS RETRIBUTION. WE
UNDERSTOOD THIS, BUT THEY TOOK
THE RISKS AND MANAGED TO SAVE
CHILDREN. AND A CRITICAL CARE
NURSE TOOK IT A STEP FURTHER.
TATIANA SAYS SHE FELL IN LOVE
WITH ONE OF THE ORPHAN CHILDREN.
SHE WORKED DESPERATELY TO KEEP
THE CHILD OF THE LIST. ARE YOU
ADOPTING KIRA? NICE TO MEET YOU
? WE MET THEM AT HOME AND
UKRAINIAN MOM WITH HER TREASURED
UKRAINIAN CHILD, KIRA. KIRA IS
ALMOST READY TO WALK. WHAT DOES
SHE MEAN TO YOU? NADA. SHE MEANS
EVERYTHING TO ME, SAYS TATIANA.
JUST DON'T EVEN KNOW TO BE
HONEST, I CAN'T IMAGINE MY LIFE
WITHOUT KIRA. A